that is in Pennsylvania hi Jeanette
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
we help oh yes thank you um I just have
a question on my husband I am kind of a
different opinion about he feels they
should take out student loans for
college just so that they can know how
to manage their money better and just
realize like you know how much money
they're taking out and just he he took
out some student loans and he is very
frugal I give him credit for that and I
didn't have any student loans and my
parents the reasoning is flawed
yeah it's flawed logic okay he wants to
teach his children to be tough and he
wants to teach them to be smart but you
don't teach a kid to drive a car about
having them be in a car wreck yeah yeah
I mean I think he said he will help them
pay it off you don't teach a kid to
drive a car by putting them into a car
wreck yeah you don't teach a kid to use
that mm-hmm bye to stay away from debt
by putting them into that right I mean I
think he wants to like be paid off for
them or help them pay it off that he
just wants them to learn and he wants
them to learn to be in debt no and then
their daddy pay it off my concern was
yeah I mean I you know he said that in
the future they mainly in American
that's hard to not take out a mortgage I
mean I don't think he's for taking a
mortgage if you don't have to but you
know he said realistically they might
have to take up something just wearing a
process of it and I mean I one is 13 and
ones 11 yeah no no no there's so many
different ways that you can teach a 13-8
11 euro how to be good stewards and how
to be disciplined when it comes to their
money are you all teaching them how to
budget right now are you teaching them
how to give save and spin I'm trying to
know is he Oh is he
yes I mean he definitely is trying to it
are they on a budget you know
no yeah yeah yeah there's different
routes of doing this and this is what
Dave and I are saying like teaching him
to get into debt teaching them how to
rack up debt teaching them how to go
into a flawed future a nightmare that's
not what you want okay we need to step
back have a conversation with him I mean
you've got at me honestly respectfully
I'm not married you can speak into this
day but you got to tell them no this is
not what we want for our kids and this
is what I went I went freedom his logic
is flawed that's the bottom line I don't
know if it's you know better I think
it's just doing the paperwork he wants
them to know how many times do I have to
tell you this and then you go back and I
think you're the one making the argument
I mean what part you call us what part
of this sounds smart I mean I don't
think it does sound smart but I mean I
know I want to respect his opinion but I
don't agree with it so I respect him and
I can respect him and say your opinions
stupid because it is give them all the
money for and let them write the check
for the tuition because it looks like we
Pike can pay for or maybe you just write
the check for the tuition and then you
put them on a budget because they've
been on a budget all through high school
from thirteen to eighteen and then when
they go to college they know how to stay
on a budget and balance a checkbook my
kids were on a budget they had a monthly
amount they had to live on in college it
was not much and we paid all the bills
direct for the college and it did not
ruin them and it did not make them
unfruitful and it did not make them
they're mean you know but they didn't
have to learn how to you know what's the
process be how is it positive learn how
to fill out paperwork for a student loan
it's not is that good I mean it's like I
need to be able to go to I need to go
down the hospital and fill out paperwork
to go into the ER just in case I need to
go into the ER some day that's just no
that's not a skill that somebody needs
to learn no it's not and you know here's
the thing you want to teach them how to
be good stewards with their money
allow them to get a job you pay for 90
percent of their school tell them they
need to save up throughout the next few
years to go towards their college
expenses that's gonna help them out now
you're really teaching them something
because the average person in America do
not budget today so if you really want
to give him a head start teach him how
to budget teach him how to live but
lo there means teach him to start
prepare for the future it's an hour job
when we have teenagers as parents and I
raised three successfully they all live
through it is not to teach them how to
be kids is to teach them how to be
adults and when you go in and you say
I'm your father I'm gonna put my arm
around you and I'm gonna teach you how
to be an adult here's how you fill out a
loan application ya you are setting that
child up for a pattern of borrowing the
rest of their life every time they need
something because my dad said it was
wise that's what's aggravating me here
Janette yeah you're this is the greatest
endorsement a kid could have is from
their dad or their mom to put their arm
around them and say oh this is smart it
may take them a decade to get over you
saying that yeah it's not smart it's not
okay it's dumb there's an epic student
loan crisis do not lead your kids into
this there is no justification for it
whatsoever you it's filling out a loan
application is not a life skill that you
have to have to be an adult that's just
not a life skill that you have to have
budgeting and working being generous
saving these are life skills that we are
and it is incumbent upon us as parents
to teach teenagers I told my kids the
whole time they're growing up my job is
not to be your friend my job is to
prepare you for adulthood so when you
leave you stay gone except to bring back
grandbabies that's your job my job is to
make sure you do not end up in the
basement because you are a financial
illiterate and they did just that day
they did they left and there they have
great boundaries and yeah you know
regularly tell Papa Dave what he can and
can't do with their kids so that's okay
as part of it yeah so you know your job
is not to teach them how to fill out a
dadgum loan application and build their
credit score that's just like
bad bad logic padlock please don't do it
your net hey I tell you what I'm gonna
send you a copy of smart money smart
kids Rachael Cruz my daughter and I
wrote together on how to raise money
smart kids it was a number one
bestseller maybe it'll help your husband
hold on I'll send it to you